er schaut schon süß aus ich Plan gerade
eine schöne Geburtstagstorte für dich
richtig süß ein tedy really Mama ja ich
will
[Musik]
gruseledy los geht's jetzt also mit ell
Torte da ich ja den Teddy backen möchte
mache ich das ganze in zwei Teilen
nämlich einmal den Boden den Bauch das
wird aus Kuchenmasse gemacht und der
Kopf wird aus Rice crispy Masse gemacht
denn Rice crispy und eigentlich muss ich
sagen wollte sie eine komplette Torte
aus Rice crispy Masse ich habe sie dann
dazu überreden können dass wir den Kopf
aus Rice crispy machen und den Rest als
Kuchen als schokerkuchen weil den
eigentlich auch jedes Kind gerne mag für
den Schokoladenkuchen habe ich jetzt
hier zwei Tortenböden gebacken und zwar
backe ich die mit meinem
mandelchokokuchen Rezept das ist mein
Standardrezept was ihr auf dem Blog
findet und dafür verrührt ihr nämlich
einfach die Eier mit Zucker Salz und
Vanilleextrakt oder tonkapaste für etwa
5 bis 6 Minuten richtig schön weißcremig
danach kommen Buttermilch und
Sonnenblumenöl dazu und werden kurz
eingerührt und im Anschluss könnt ihr
einfach die trockenen Zutaten vermischen
also mehl Backpulver etwas Mandeln die
sind bereits gemahlen und natürlich auch
Kakao und Backpulver und die Zutaten
werden nur noch ganz kurz eingerührt den
Teig füllt ihr dann in zwei vorbereitete
Tortenringe die haben 20 cm Durchmesser
und liegen bei mir auf dem
Springformboden so läuft nämlich
wirklich gar nichts aus das ganze wird
dann bei 170° oberunterhitze gebacken
für etwa 5 40 bis 50 Minuten danach
macht ihr die Stäbchenprobe nehmt die
tortenbüden aus dem Ofen heraus und
lasst sie ungefähr 10 Minuten abkühlen
jetzt können Sie direkt aus der Form
herausgelöst werden und dürfen auf dem
abkühlgitter Abkühlen hier sind also
jetzt die fertigen Tortenböden die werde
ich gleich noch durchschneiden und dann
einfach einpacken und schon mal in
Kühlschrank stellen sowas könnt ihr auch
immer gut vorbereiten und einfrieren
falls ihr z.B eine Woche später erst
Backen wollt und nicht so den Stress
haben wollt dann habt ihr einfach schon
vor eingefrorene Tortenböden und seid
dann beim backen wirklich perfekt und so
mache ich es jetzt auch heute ist bei
uns Freitag ich habe die jetzt gebacken
werde sie gleich schneiden und
einfrieren verpackt natürlich und am
Montag nächste Woche dann einfach alles
dekorieren jetzt kommt die Rice crispy
Masse dran auch die kann ich jetzt schon
vorbereiten und zwar verwendet ihr für
Rice Crispies immer Marshmallows plus
Rice Crispies also haferpops reispops
was auch immer da könnt ihr gerne mal im
Zerealien Regal nachschauen bisher hatte
ich immer schokocrispies genommen aber
was es auch gibt und das finde ich R
richtig cool ist hier sind diese
haferfleaks von kölnflocken ihr kennt
kölnflocken wahrscheinlich alle von den
Haferflocken zart und kernig aber die
haben auch wirklich ganz viele andere
Produkte wie verschiedene Müsli Sorten
Porridge und alles Mögliche aus
Haferflocken und hier diese haferflakes
gibt's in schoko und eben mit Honig und
ich werde jetzt einfach beides mischen
so vom Verhältnis her braucht ihr
Marshmallows 350 g und 350 g von den
Zerealien und ich habe das jetzt so
bisschen aufgeteilt hier dunkel und hell
und das mache ich jetzt einfach so dass
ich die Marshmallows kurz erstmal in der
Mikrowelle Schmelze bis sie schön weich
sind man sieht es nicht aber es sind
ungefähr immer so zweieinhalb bis D
Minuten je nach
[Musik]
Mikrowelle jetzt hier die Butter dazu
geben und wie ihr sehen könnt die
Marshmallows sehen nicht heiß aus aber
die sind richtig
und dann kommen einfach die Flakes dazu
und werden eingerührt und am Ende nehme
ich auch noch die Hände zum
Kneten wenn es dann so bisschen
abgekühlt ist könnt ihr praktisch eure
Hände fetten mit etwas Butter oder
backtrpray und das ganze einfach hier
kneten und das macht echt D meisten Spaß
jetzt einfach
zusammendrücken schön
kneten und darus fen wir einen Teddy
Knopf äh
[Musik]
Kopf so ist erstmal der Teddy Kopf ihr
müsst jetzt noch gar nicht großartig was
Formen aber es sollte schon so ein
bisschen in die Richtung gehen unten so
bisschen Schnauze hier oben so und dann
packe ich den jetzt einfach in
Frischhaltefolie ein lass ihn schön
aushärten und den könnt ihr jetzt
wirklich 3 4 5 6 Tage aushärten lassen
ihr könnt aber auch theoretisch in
Stunde schon weiter verwenden aber da
ich jetzt die Torte Schritt für Schritt
vorbereite packe ich das alles
ein und dann geht's bei mir in drei
Tagen erst
weiter jetzt geht's ans Füllen der Torte
die Tortenböden sind noch richtig schön
eingefroren und ich habe jetzt hier
gerade noch eine ganach hergestellt eine
ganach ist eine Creme aus Schokolade und
Sahne und dafür kocht ihr einfach die
Sahne auf schaltet den Herd dann aus
dann kommt die Schokolade dazu und und
wird so lange eingerührt bis sie
geschmolzen ist das Ganze darf dann bei
Raumtemperatur abkühlen bis sie eine
schöne streichfige Konsistenz hat Ich
habe mich jetzt hier für
zartbitterganache entschieden könnt aber
auch Vollmilch machen oder weiße
Kouvertüre verwenden ganz wie ihr
möchtet jetzt könnt ihr hier die
einzelnen Tortenböden mit Marmelade
bestreichen das macht so ein bisschen
saftiger und dann kommt jeweils ganach
dazwischen die ganach hat jetzt diese
Konsistenz also nicht so fest aber auch
nicht flüssig die kommt jetzt hier rein
und durch den kalten Torten wurden wird
sie gleich fest dann kann direkt der
nächste drauf und falls ihr es braucht
könnt ihr gerne zum Stabilisieren noch
einen Holzstab in die Mitte geben dann
fällt euch die Torte nicht um ich habe
jetzt übrigens meine leckere
Orangenmarmelade die passt einfach vom
Geschmack her perfekt dazu die hat
Orange mit drin Vanille Sternanis Zimt
die ist richtig gut da findet ihr auch
ein Rezept auf meinem Kanal aber ihr
dürft natürlich eure Torte füllen womit
ihr möchtet was euch oder euren Kindern
am besten schmeckt
[Musik]
bauen wir das praktisch so auf wie ich
Torten normalerweise nie Fülle also
mitten im
Hubel dann bekomme ich nämlich schon
direkt eine rundlichere
Form die Torte kurz in den Kühlschrank
aber die ist schon richtig schön fest
man sieht auch hier am Rand dass die G
schon fest ist denn dann kann ich sie
direkt schon schön
[Musik]
zuschneiden alles was ich wegschneide
hebe ich aber noch auf und ich habe hier
einfach meine
Zeichnung die ich mir immer wieder
anschaue um zu gucken ob die Form des
Teddys dann auch
passt
[Musik]
ein kleiner runter
Dönerspieß das wird süß ist noch ein
sehr runder Teddy aber der ist halt wohl
genährt der hat zu viel Torte gegessen
von
mir dann kommt jetzt hier einfach mal
die erste ganaschicht drauf um die
ganzen Krümel zu binden
[Musik]
jetzt ist der Körper erstmal mit der
ersten Schicht ganage eingekleidet ihr
seht es wird auch richtig schön fest
direkt das heißt ich kann hier kurz
sauber machen alle kuchenkrümmel zur
Seite legen und dann noch mal eine
schöne glatte Schicht drauf
[Musik]
machen
so ST der Körper ja da der Bauch doch
sieht gut aus ich kN jetzt mal Fondant
schokoladenfondant hier habe ich
Vollmilch schokoladenfondant das ist
Fondant mit Schokolade schmeckt sehr gut
und riecht auch sehr gut ich muss ja
generell sagen dass ich nicht so der
vonant Fan bin aber bei Motivtorten
kommt man nicht huch kommt man nicht so
wirklich drum herum außer man nimmt
modellier Marzipan ist natürlich noch
leckerer finde
ich so jetzt wird es hier einmal
ausgerollt und dann werde ich aber
zuerst einmal den Kopf eindecken
deswegen Rolle ich es gar nicht zu dünn
aus denn sonst müsste ich jetzt den Kopf
des Teddys noch mit Ganache bestreichen
dass es glatt ist ansonsten kommt
nämlich diese Rice crispy Struktur durch
wenn es nicht ganz so dünn ausrollt
überdeckt das
normalerweise
ich habe jetzt hier den Kopf des Teddys
ich weiß s immer bisschen gruselig aus
am Anfang den habe ich jetzt hier
einfach auf einem tortendummy mit einem
schaschlpieß dass er einfach gut hält
jetzt kommt es hier
drauf und dann schneide ich hier den
übrigen vonant
weg
[Musik]
und dann hier unten schön
verschließen Überschuss einfach
[Musik]
weg sieht immer bisschen brutal aus aber
das gehört sich so
[Applaus]
so jetzt Trick 17 nehmt euch ein Stück
von dant und es schön glatt etwas
bäckerstärke über die Torte streuen und
dann mit dem Stück von dant einfach die
Oberfläche schön glätten guck du mal wie
das super funktioniert
hier
so polieren wir mal die
teddyglatze die zweite fondantrunde wird
jetzt ein bisschen dünner ausgerollt
denn die Torte ist ja schön glatt das
heißt einfach so dünn wie ihr es haben
möchtet 2 bis 3 mm etwa und dann kann
ich die Torte etwas mit backtrenspray
einfetten damit der Fondant auch gut
haftet denn die Ganache die wird schon
ganz schön fest und trocken
[Musik]
dann
drüberlegen und von oben nach unten
schön glatt
streichen und hier mache ich es jetzt
auch so einfach um den Teddy später gut
wieder von der Platte wegnehmen zu
können packe ich hier den Fondant auch
einmal
[Musik]
drunter
ich habe jetzt hier ein Rundholz 1 cm
und damit werde ich jetzt den Kopf auf
dem Teddy Körper befestigen und damit
das Rundholz aber auch schön den Kopf
reingeht muss man es natürlich vorher
anspitzen geht mit einem ganz normalen
spitzer hier unten im Kuchen klappt ganz
gut
Z ohne dass ich ihn verlz
[Musik]
muss Gott ist das
schwer die Rice crispy
Masse also am besten ist wenn man die
Rice crispy Masse vorher schon bisschen
durchlöchert den schönen Kopf nicht
zerstören ich muss jetzt einmal drücken
es tut mir
leid
oh Gott jetzt schon wieder faltig wisst
jetzt ist sch jetzt hat er wieder
falten der
Stress so muss wieder glatt machen hier
oben komm
her krieg gleich deine roseen
Augenpads immer diese
stressfalten der schaut schon süß
[Musik]
aus Biss
Buckel ich hoffe der fällt
nicht was
W damit der Teddy ein richtiger Teddy
wird fehlen jetzt natürlich noch Ohren
die Arme und auch die Beine und damit
ihr den Fondant fest bekommt braucht ihr
ein bisschen CMC Pulver also Zellulose
Pulver könnt es hier neten und dann
werde ich jetzt erstmal die Ohren Formen
und je mehr CMC Pulver ihr nhmt umso
schneller wird's auch fest aber umso
schwieriger lässt sich davon dann auch
verarbeiten alternativ könnt ihr auch
Blütenpaste nehmen und die mit einkneten
aber die würde jetzt hier natürlich die
fondantfarbe verändern deswegen finde
ich jetzt hier aktuell einfach Z Z am
besten ich knete das jetzt kurz
ordentlich
[Musik]
ein da haleren
und zwei kugelnformen wenn davon dann so
ein bisschen kleben sollte könnt ihr
einfach bisschen bäckerstärke nehmen
dann wird er auch wieder schön
matt damit die Ohren gleich auch am Kopf
halten nehme ich einfach einen
Zahnstocher oder
schaschligspieß dann hier rein mit etwas
Essbarem Kleber
befestigen die lass ich jetzt hier kurz
antrocknen und forme direkt noch das
Innenteil dass so eine zweite Farbe
entsteht das heißt ich nehme jetzt
meinen Fondant und Pack da noch bisschen
weiß und gelb
dazu dafür braucht jetzt einfach zwei
kleinere Kugeln drückt sie flach und
klebt sie dann ins Ohr
[Musik]
rein
jetzt wo die Füße gut eingepackt sind
kommen sie jetzt mit der glatten Seite
gleich hier an die Torte ich klebe das
dann so dran und ich werde jetzt kein
Bein modellieren weil ich finde das wird
jetzt bisschen zu aufwendig werden und
dann sieht's auch nicht mehr so süß aus
das heißt die Füße kommen vorne dran mit
kleinen Dekorationen unten drauf und
dann vielleicht nur um den Part drüber
zu verdecken so eine kleine fondantwurst
wir gucken gleich kommen jetzt erst noch
hier unter die Füße die Parts dran so
das aufwendigste amfondant dass man ihn
immer immer immer immer immer immer
kneten
muss am besten hab so einen Assistenten
schrästrich Assistentin dabei die immer
von D knetet fühlt euch nicht
angesprochen aber tol und Daniela
[Musik]
also heute ist Leben am Limit ich sag's
euch so knapp war der vonant diesem Haus
noch
nie guckt euch
das also jetzt darf hier nichts mehr
schieflaufen nichts mehr passieren denn
Fondant ist jetzt alle ich habe jetzt
nur noch den hell gefärbten Fondant aber
schokoladenfondant ist jetzt
aus ich habe jetzt nämlich hier die Arme
noch überzogen denn die Arme waren mir
sonst zu flach gucken wir mal ob das
hält hier so wie ich das
möchte probieren wir jetzt ich glaube so
kleine Pfötchen innen rein das mache ich
[Musik]
noch mich nervt so ein bisschen
tatsächlich dass die Arme jetzt nicht so
glatt sind denn mein Fondant ist
ausgegangen und wir kriegen jetzt nicht
so schnell frischen Fondant her das
heißt ich habe einfach bei den Armen bei
dieser Rice crispy Masse nicht glatt
genug gearbeitet und der Fondant ist
leider zu dünn das heißt dort hat es
nicht ausgereicht und leider
zellulitarme ist okay damit kämpfen wir
Frauen auch nicht an den Armen aber an
den Beinen was soll's macht dir jetzt
auch nichts
so ma ich mal die Ohren
dran F Bohrmaschine
hier ich glaub Bohrmaschine W echt nicht
schlecht W Brenner wenn man ihnmer
braucht ja klar das war jetzt
[Musik]
klar so also für einen normalen Teddy
einer der nicht horrormäßig wird fehlen
jetzt eigentlich nur noch die Augen ich
kleb es euch mal auf einfach nur damit
ihr seht wie es aussehen würde wenn das
ein süßer kleiner goldiger Teddy wä
okay so ist ein süßer
[Musik]
Teddy jetzt wird aus dem Teddy ein
horroreddy wie Ella sich es gewünscht
hat sagen nehmen mal direkt die Augen ab
machen ein paar Pflaster hin bisschen
Skelett bisschen Klebeband bisschen von
allem ich guck mal was draus
wird
[Musik]
irgendwie macht halt auch Spaß ne die
Torte zu zerstören muss ich schon
sage man könnte meinen ich habe Spaß
dran ich meine da gibt jetzt halt auch
kein Richtig oder Falsch ne tedy wird
einfach zerstört Grusel
ty
[Musik]
ich muss sagen die ist ganz schön cool
geworden richtig gut sobald man ein
bisschen Pulverfarbe auf Torten
verwendet also lebensmittelpulverfarbe
bekommt so eine Motivtorte einfach so
eine so ein 3deekt einfach es gibt Tiefe
es gibt Schatten es gibt einfach so
einen schönen Effekt deswegen bin ich
echt begeistert auch von der Torte ich
wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachbacken
schreibt mir auch gerne mal welche
meiner Motivtorten euch bisher am besten
gefallen hat macht's gut bis zum
nächsten Mal Rezept gibt's natürlich wie
immer auf sellies-blog.de und in meiner
[Musik]
App
I don't
any